(air whooshing)
(electricity rippling)
(drum beating)
(hip music)
- Dr Mikhail Varshavski is
a family medicine physician.
- You have this massive
following on YouTube.
You're trying to do something different
to what ordinary doctors are trying to do.
(hip music)
- [Newscaster] The news
has come out that he
saved a man's life on a flight to Israel.
- Dr. Mike is coming.
- Yeah.
- Dr. Mike is coming so.
- He's back, yeah.
- [Woman] He's compassionate.
He's knowledgeable.
- We want to get your take on this--
- Dr. Mike is here to
show us how it's done.
(feet tapping)
- All right, ready?
(playful music)
- Knowledge is seeping
into her mind.
- Knowledge is power.
- Why do I sweat so much
more than normal people?
- It's right here.
- What?
(coffee splashing)
- Collagen, what about collagen?
- Can I overdose on Claritin?
- Should I be concerned
that I pee all the time?
- What are your thoughts in general
about the vaping situation?
- I hope she's not
gonna shock the patient.
Oh my God, please tell
me she's not gonna, no!
The right lung, let's get it outta here.
This is not the way you perform surgery.
Bright and early day, time to
be a doctor.
(hip electronic music)
(spitting)
(laughing)
(plane engine humming)
(basketball thudding)
- I will walk out on you!
- Jungle juice.
(laughing)
- Who feeds this to babies?
- Definitely not the way you do this.
(shouting softly)
(hip electronic music)